mr president mâcon
mr president sassoli mr prime
minister costa ladies and gentlemen
dear european citizens of european citizens
i am delighted to finally be back in
strasbourg for this
very special europe day this city
symbolizes a large part of our
history
it  is therefore normal that we are here
to talk about our future
and when I think of this future is at
this conference
I think of elders in strasbourg
antoine de saint-exupéry and in
particular his book la terre des
hommes published just before the second
war  world whose unique and poetic style
he gives grid to the fear and to the
pain to the love and to the hope which are
in each of us he reminds us of
the importance of living with each
other but also with the world  nature
that surrounds us is our duty to
bequeath a better world to our children
although the context is different what
it tells us is not true for today
's world  Today there is a
particular quote which for me
embodies Europe as well as the duty of this
conference I quote and but it is
not looking at each other looking at each other
together in the same direction
Roman high school girls
do you have like france it is necessary in
europe in to debate jewelery auctions to
want me one of the union of concerned
that has always capture these areas as well
decision
wario land project of the ninja smiles
mrs ashton hot and the notes a talk
show  social policy a clause for
the tigers compromised
today is the french striker who has
just moved to toulouse where is the real
problem with wim hoste the six bulls
from or at the critical one compresses entry
in something too polite follow up and
what ever  is great barra do believe la
tuscane france is he will opportunity to
bring together and will find face to this
price aims to generate 6 2 and richard notes
and death to make the power of good bye
koudou faux life pipeline for two
points according to opinionway this jewel pin's
wants to be a star is no time to predict
since a drummer especially to save
fail the rich in the 2nd round isolated for
example sam vials lawyers or close to
do it to me everything and anywhere
else  pine falls from your twenties
touches the decision also belongs to we
can't find more than two years we don't
need to woman of honor and have peace
is not a scaling to this burden of an
opportunity all high held alps
like purple  must to the europeans
yes so important address one we look at
the world as global is fragmented for
love contradictions confrontation
reminds 100% except a banal havas kengo
gives my girlfriend and funny and wilbur
formative by dassault manulife then on
manila by the company ada godefroy ma
wii knee to find a way to talk about you
i want to be used by the way to do that
day by day
ort d'anna
hear from ladies and stow the experience in
limoges
brian pearce mise and stéphane friendship
task and people for ever and stores
opportunities from them to grow up to
learn and to take risks and more than
anything and doctors many people oggi
the  oblivion is extremely simple control of the
live santa 'future' mopipi world
the texture wiimote petrov of am dam
things darwini of new form of solidarity
and sochaux just between generation sk
tongres and nina ricci north bagua zone
actions carried out with synths and a half
before the crazy match
so we will go to the pana to turn we do
concrete there was still some left for mr ghinzu
quickly find you can be found side by side
and pandemics laayoune 44 min 16 s to
barika be born because raffi torres would
pinch it was also  a myth inbound
november cent rale roland garros
philippe lives in brooklyn in
meetings narration is going to be in nature
omeyyads old gentleman owens
hendon starch concern in horna
frühling zone maps  vinther free air
old clichés fine that affects the
policies of calling on August 10 on my
name and structuring social dialogue
guénard ascione from aruba suffers a life
via the micro cloud talkative
ah no I'm kidding birds thread red
pay in one sound of music  hate
schumann zana clair a madness that damascus
is it not seen this so of creeks in
conflict whaou to the puppet times
did I say that our sons of steam spiel
of the climates valves of cannes aulas is
happy that they know of redemption kraft
Greek crisis fund
my body is a new hope he has always been
added the best way the rivers engineered
wild wind river this year mme bachelot
ohd act of necessity skills with
the barges because they need to be
done here is not so largo time magazine
et  against the backdrop of 200 shows and shu fu hao
generation and for john rishton
ladies and gentlemen the example
and empathy of young people since the start of
the pandemic inspires us and gives us
hope and responsibility.
to build a better world
just a month ago i had an
intimate and moving recollection when i first
became a grandmother
the first hug with my granddaughter
was one of those moments that puts
things into perspective and  who reminds me of
what is really important in life
in this moment of tenderness and love
she showed me one thing that we
must never forget
we are still young enough to
believe in the world and we are still old
enough to do it  a difference
here is what unites the
generations between them and by holding the
little one in my arms I did what
all new parents and
grandparents do I thought of all the
possibilities that will be free round  to her
i tried to imagine imagined world the
world she will grow up in
would there be forests or fom that
will only exist in her books and
movies what her career will be like her
jobs and  the technologies it
will need
the disparities and social inequalities
will they be more pronounced at the
narrowest and what europe it will do such
as defending at it will it be more
respectful more diverse
will it be united where will it be  divided
as by its past these questions may
seem too
far off when we have
are two immediate challenges but the
direction we take today will
determine the answers we
seek for tomorrow and that is
precisely why we
need this conference is why we
we have to get going now we
approach this task with humility
recognizing that things are not
all perfect but also with the
pride of knowing where our union comes from
and the conviction of what it must
always do and for that I will
end here  where i started with
antoine de saint-exupéry because it was
he who inspired jean monnet with his
phrase
the most beautiful profession of man is  t the
job of uniting men to us to
continue to do so
thank you and long live the rank
as long as I did not do the president alone
so the 430 million Europeans have
lived confined for a year to counter
a virus which has had an impact  deep into
their daily life their mobility their
job their morale of course today
they have the opportunity to learn lessons
for themselves from this unprecedented episode
to consider the future in terms of health
, economics and perhaps even in terms of
philosophical indicates bic years of
profession